we'll have more on the trial of gelane
maxwell that's jeffrey epstein's former
associate beginning later today right
here in new york maxwell as you know is
accused of sex trafficking of minors and
transporting a minor for criminal sexual
activity
she faces a maximum of 70 years in
prison she has pleaded not guilty to all
charges and insist she had nothing to do
with epstein's alleged abuse of teenage
girls
one of epstein's alleged victims was
jennifer arose who says she was just 15
when epstein raped her jennifer arose
joins us now she's with her lawyer and
she says her best friend eric lerner we
welcome you both
thank you thank you for coming jennifer
i'm so sorry it's under these
circumstances because for us these are
words on a paper but for you this is
your real life so let's start with you
never met galaine maxwell but you want
to be in court today why
um i just think it's because um
being that epstein isn't here it gives
me a good reason to kind of
have my day in court
it's not going to justify anything but
it does make me feel good for the other
victims you know that they're going to
have their day in court
to speak their mind and you know
hopefully get closure what does your day
in court look like for you what do you
mean by that
what do you want i mean of course i want
any of the co-conspirators or anybody
involved i mean it was a huge web a big
enterprise
and i want everybody who's involved to
you know face their day in court and
have justice
now you were 15 years old how did you
come in contact with epstein at the age
of 15
well i
was actually
in my school my talent high school i
wanted to be in a musical theater
broadway was my dream and
i got contacted by
one of his recruiters
could have been one of galen's
recruit uh somebody she recruited we're
not 100 sure i'm hoping to find that out
maybe in the trial
to see if you know i could find out who
my recruiter was so they approached you
and said what basically in front of my
school just kind of being very friendly
and
open
you know where you from
um where do you live
and then as you get more and more just i
guess
getting to know somebody you know i
started telling her about my father had
passed tragically when i was very young
and
just times were tough um i remember
she'd wanted to hang out but i was
starving if i didn't eat in school then
i would have to run home to go
and have dinner because i couldn't
afford like pizza or hot dog and then
she introduces you to epstein basically
just just like after you know i would
say over a month period a little longer
you know she was like i know somebody
that was such a fatherly figure to me
i think um you know it was it's such a
blessing that you met me
because he could help you in so many
ways
um
and on top of that he knows a lot of
people in the you know the acting
industry and all you know
uh
it's just you when you're that young
you're very vulnerable you know
now galen has said
is pleading not guilty to all charges in
this case
again you haven't met her but what do
you think when you hear that she's that
she's saying i had nothing to do with
this i wasn't aware of it i was not
involved
i mean i think if
if epstein was here i think he would
have said the same thing
i mean i don't think
any you know
predator or you know somebody
who's charged with these things are
going to
um
say that they're not not guilty mm-hmm
we have eric what are you yeah we have a
great
what are you hoping eric to learn from
this trial
well several things gal uh first of all
we're hoping as jen mentioned that they
the prosecution in pre-trial filings had
mentioned a co-conspirator
in the epstein complaint it was
co-conspirators plural we're hoping to
learn the identity of the
co-conspirators and maybe that will shed
light on who jen's recruiter was as well
we're hoping that
we learn who else was involved in this
big web of people and this network this
basically sex trafficking network that
is alleged by prosecution
and we're also hoping that if there's
any victims who haven't come forward yet
that this trial basically gives them a
voice to to do that you know jen you had
filed a suit against him and you said
that the damage inflicted upon you was
severe and long-lasting
so how are you getting through what does
it mean severe and long-lasting i can
only imagine at the age of 15.
um
how old are you now by the way i'm 34.
mm-hmm sometimes i forget
um i do two right i'm like i'm always 20
yeah um basically you know as of right
now
when i was young growing up i focused so
much on just like the negative
about it all and trying to get over it
for such a long period of time
i think right now like i just want to
focus on the positive
of the fact that i
didn't want to come forward and i did
come forward
and
you know he helped me so much just to
give me the courage
and it was hard to come forward of
course i was nervous you don't want to
be judged you don't want to be not
believed
you know so the fact that i did come
forward and i am a strong woman you know
it's not um
i don't want it to define me but at the
same time like it helps so many other
women so it's such a blessing to know
that i did you know speak my mind and my
truth
that i got countless letters and emails
so i wanted to continue on
helping other women so
i we started a nonprofit called the
survivors initiative well hopefully
being in the court will give you some
closure and will be
part of the healing process yeah 100
hopefully i think i so far i'm in the
right direction and like i said
um starting the nonprofit has given me a
purpose
which you could find out more
information on survivors initiative.org
and i just gail i just want to point out
that jen was the first victim to come
forward on tv
uh making allegations that jeffrey
epstein had raped her so that opened the
door and the floodgates for other
victims to feel comfortable coming
forward yeah i mean staying silent they
said doesn't help you and doesn't help
anyone doesn't help anyone we thank you
for coming forward thank you so much
we're following the case too thank you
thank you both thank